when we were doing wild boys and
presumably
like jackass and then maybe even with
the movies as well like you've always
got like in your director
mind the idea that when you submit
the edit of the episode that there's
going to be some pushback on like the
powers that be in putting it out whether
that's mtv's standards and practices if
it's the mpaa the motion picture
association they're going to watch it
and they're going to say hey you can't
include this certain thing and it
actually started way back in big brother
the brother we call it red herring we
call them red herrings yeah we learned
early on that like
to get what we want we have to kind of
go further
for some reason it's a negotiation like
it's not just
black and white you can't do this you
can't do that right it's subjective it's
subjective and we're dealing with people
so
we learned oh well let's just cut it out
load it up with the gnarly [ __ ] over the
top [ __ ] and big brother we used to
submit you know crazy pictures that we
knew weren't going but they would see
him and said you can't do that you can't
do that right and then the thing we
wanted looked way less
radical and like all right well can we
keep that one as long as you get rid of
these three you can keep that one got it
right and then
that was that was it was always like
part of our like production schedule
shooting like oh let's do this for a red
we should not be i mean like it's gonna
shoot me i've i've talked about it
before but it really just shoots us in
the foot when we expose
and we can can we do this no leave it
i'm just saying like it's stuff
we had a huge one on the new movie was
just like we loaded it
and
they singled out all the shots that we
knew weren't going
and
left alone the ones i didn't even have
to negotiate it was like
because we put in
six minutes of just pure [ __ ] filth
knowing that this right
less
filthy filth would get through so so and
and we've always had like in both
jackass and wild boys it's always we've
had this love affair with mascot
costumes yeah it's like the the night
monkeys the the the pandas
you know like we did a lot of it and
when we were in russia even though i
don't think it was an animal that was at
all into no it was pandas that were not
indigenous to china yeah no you were it
was polar polar bears in in russia which
yeah it made sense okay there was pandas
in japan which didn't that was loomis's
idea today right anderson
so with the the the
polar bear suits in russia and always
with these costumes it was like a
montage bit you know it would be music
driven and like cut together this
montage and so
the note came back from the standards
and practices department when you
submitted the russia episode and they
said
um please strike meaning please remove
the shot of
the polar bears getting
[Applause]
[Laughter]
legitimately to pay for hookers
we cut
we cut uh holes in the the polar bear
costume to make for our wieners to come
out
we have these big gigantic polar bear
hats to be clear
jp came out to direct that bit and he
was really good at like directing that
kind of [ __ ]
[Applause]
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never been allowed to do for jackass and
a lot of it is flagrantly illegal so
it's adults only and if you live in any
of these states then you better go to
stevo.com and check out my tour schedule
hurry up and get your tickets too
because it's selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude